لنلقي نظره على ما سيحدث خلال التحقيق وما
يليه مع الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد
ترامب لجنه المحلفين الكبرى ستراجع لائحه
الاتهام بحق ترامب فماذا اذا اصدرت اللجنه
قرارا بادانه ترامب حينها سيتم تقديم
لائحه التهام وامر القبض واختاروا محامي
ترامب ولن يتم الاعلان عن لائحه الاتهام
حتى اعتقال واحتجاز ترامب ولكن ماذا اذا
سلم دونالد ترامب نفسه للسلطات في منهاته
في هذه الحاله سيتجنب مشهد الاعتقال العام
ولاحقا سيتم اخذ بصمه رئيس السابق والتقاط
صورته
توجد استثناءات لرئيس السابق ترامب عاده
ما ينقل المتهم الى زنزانه بعد التحقيق
ولكن الامر سيختلف مع التراب لكونه رئيسا
سابقا وعملاء الخدمه السريه ملزمون
بحمايته في جميع الاماكن سؤال اخر هل
سيكون دونالد ترامب مقيده اليدين في حاله
ترامب من المرجح ان تتم مناقشات مع فريقه
القانوني لعدم تكبير يديه ماذا سيحدث في
المحكمه اثناء مثوله امام المحكمه
التمهيديه سيطلب القاضي من ترامب الاعتراف
بالتهم الوارده ومن غير المتوقع ان يقرر
ترامب هذه التهم متى ستبدا ومتى ستنتهي
المحاكمه تستغرق القضايا في نيويورك شهورا
وغالبا اكثر من عام ومن شبه المؤكد ان
يلجا محاموه للدفع بان تهمى جاءت في وقت
غير مناسب في الفتره التي تسبق انتخابات
العام المقبل